wait are you serious yeah what's wrong
up is you look like you're about to go
to a hockey game
what's wrong about you're not going to a
yeah I'm going to be getting a sibling
for a week common misconceptions of
being an only child is that you don't
know how to share you want it to always
be all about you just kind of true I'm
honestly really excited to kind of have
that companionship I've always wanted a
brother when I was younger I went to a
mall Santa and I asked for an older
brother for Christmas and he laughed in
my face I didn't believe in Santa for
that much longer after that so I'm about
to find out who my siblings gonna be I'm
so excited and also very nervous here we
go oh
[Music]
Nayla oh I'm so happy oh my gosh I'm so
excited we're gonna be brethren so this
week my parents are coming in town for
vacation so we're gonna be cooking them
a meal together
oh we're also gonna be going on a family
outing together and at the end of the
week we're going to be taking a family
portrait okay I'm very excited for that
I had no clue you know me yeah I don't
know why anyone complains about having a
sibling
why should probably be like arguing
today too Nayla is heading down to La
Vie and we're about to meet her and go
to a museum together are you ready
I was a little nervous at first I know
how my family operates I don't really
know how other people's family operates
but then I fell in love with them like
instantly you walk up to a family that's
not yours especially parents they either
go by mr. and mrs. something very formal
but Ben's parents were just like mom and
dad and I was like okay cool
so she just told us it was four blocks
that way we went to the wrong wax museum
at first I think that kind of like broke
the ice out of family dysfunction we
were able to share that moment and it
kind of set the tone for the rest of the
day we made it alright let's do this it
was crazy because at one point in time
we were walking I was kind of like a
little bit ahead of Ben and his parents
and this guy he was like oh you should
like smile more no he said yeah and I
was like that's my sister dad
you're about to get your ass kicked if
you keep messing with her okay the wax
museum we kind of really like break the
ice and then the family dinner the next
day was also a really great time your
are we my Trader Joe's we're going to
get dinner for our parents and get
groceries for the week yeah can you cook
I can cook yeah mom dad we're home oh
yeah it definitely felt like a family
dinner we like we're talking about a lot
of like pretty deep thank you oh yeah we
would be like we got into it I took on
like the main course tonight I made the
salad the premade salad premade stuff
but I think that was good because it was
fun to like make something for our
parents and then also that I feel like
gave an opportunity for you like really
sit down
[Music]
the next day we had a family photo shoot
and it was corneas [ __ ] it gives new
meaning to the word Facebook I think at
that point it was like we were so
familiar with each other it was like so
fun and as an only child like I know I
never went to the mall and didn't like
any sort of portraits because it's like
that's something you usually do with
siblings my dad says that he's gonna
send you our newsletter this year our
family and he wants to like including
one of those pictures all right so we
just finished our photo shoot yeah it
was awesome yeah it was a lot of fun
I've never done that I'm gonna go back
and do it again
[Laughter]
he recently moved out here and every
week she's been spending it with me she
spent the day and the night with us she
ends up becoming like the cousin we were
trying to not have to cook anything so
we got chicken and waffles and look at
the others laughing yeah so I tried I've
got a whole box I think we both kind of
have an understanding of when it's time
to be like Oh like yeah let's chat and
then it's like your thing I'm gonna do
my thing and like we'll come back
together eventually also know common
courtesy like it's different if we were
like younger or we didn't learn manners
they're so so cute I think the only time
we kind of ran into anything was like
you in the bathroom because the stuff
that I have to do the longest on the
bathroom I just would like to say all
the stuff that I do I need a sink for it
I'm not gonna like shave in your like
kitchen it's a process but we went out
at night with your friends and it was
like a situation where I was out of my
element
I felt so included I just felt like
we're in it together yeah good night
brothers see you tomorrow it's been a
week since we've been siblings it tried
both of us like this week Wow
we're hanging out on Saturday night I
love whips out of her garage and we hear
this stud
I'm like oh my god you hit something and
then it clicks on my head I was like
that's my car we've turned around and
sure enough there's my car parked
outside hey it was so funny - because
you were like oh my god don't tell mom
and dad either gonna hate me they're
gonna hate me it was it was tiring in
times I was out of my element but I'm so
glad that I got this time with you I
definitely feel like I consider you like
family in some sense you know yeah it's
like wild we just think we click yeah
thank you got a little peek of my family
and like I got a peek of like your
family here the whole week there was
kind of this unspoken thing where I feel
like you had my back and I had yours I
appreciate that
I'm kind of happy we didn't share the
same room I like to masturbate so